everybody sha McInnis here with the GS
news update you know that old saying of
life imitates art well let's talk about
Fox News
it seems that Fox News has allegedly
copied the BioShock Infinite logo
rebranded for their news program in case
you haven't played bioshock infinite yet
it's a game partly about a class
struggle on the floating city of
columbia ruled by racists and zealots
who use American patriotism as a tool to
control the population Fox News on the
other hand is well GameSpot's a CBS
division so it's not really our place to
say but it's Fox News come on you've
seen the logo appeared on a segment on
Fox interviewing the governor of Texas
about immigration there are several
aspects of the logo that are similar
including the shape of the borders the
gold embossed red text the Stars and of
course the American flag in response to
a question on Twitter asking if the logo
was copyrighted Ken Levine creator of
Bioshock tweeted I think the Fox thing
is just a little ironic and funny it's
fair use for sure hashtag not outraged
now this isn't the first time that
BioShock Infinite art has been used out
of context by right-wing Americans a
group associated with the Tea Party
posted this image of an anti-immigration
cartoon on Facebook without being aware
of its context in the game spoiler its
propaganda used by the founders who were
upper-class white supremacists rewriting
history to support their agenda there's
probably a stir an email rippling
through Republican Party's warning
everyone to make sure their graphics
aren't from video games or actually just
not from pipe shot infinite for more
news make sure to come back to GameSpot
calm
you